[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es gay semailles être un jeu dans
lequel des candidats doit découvrir
l'âge de quelqu'un
découvrez le nouveau format de la c8 et
guess my prénom pour ça bonsoir voila je
me sens prêt bon soir bienvenue sur le
plateau de guest my prénom tout de suite
vous propose d'accueillir nos candidats
du jour il s'agit
cyril est déjà là nous accueillons tout
de suite sophie applaudissements pour
elle
[Applaudissements]
keith haring merci sûr
je trouve la trouve très belle
resplendissante
alors juste une candidate je ne la
connaissais pas mais j'ai l'impression
que le feeling passe déjà et c'est une
bonne nouvelle
sophie série le bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous venez des coulisses et
c'est sympa de votre part cyril vous
êtes professeur agrégé de lettres
classiques oui oui et oui oui mais face
à ce qu'on m'a dit ça de lettres
classiques d2 albi rosen singer drôle
oui oui venez vous sophie vous gérez un
dépôt-vente dépôt vente dans lequel vous
officier aux côtés des n'aura malagré
d'olivier minne et 2 michel polnareff
s'est ancré le casting
ce fut serré vous êtes prêts bien sûr
vont les devoir deviner le prénom de
notre inconnu jouant tout de suite à des
semailles prénom
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme ça à brûle pourpoint ce que vous
avez une petite idée du prénom de notre
inconnu oui oui et sophie roger roger
cheryl jean mahmoud alors vous n'y est
pas d'après vous réfléchissez bien il a
une tête de poix terron cheikh hussein
et trois en rongeurs et bien alors tout
ce qu'on vous donne un premier indice
que pour vous aider à découvrir le
prénom de notre inconnu indices musicale
on va pas trop révéler ce serait dommage
mais ça a dû vous mettre sur la voie
vous avez bien entendu ce que vous avez
entendu je me présente je m'appelle en
gris est-ce que vous avez une idée voilà
mais on commence à un henry serait trop
simple écoute chez nous à vous allez
voir un deuxième avis mais juste avant
voici pour vous chers france 12 la
question sms qui vous permettra
peut-être de remporter la somme que la
somme de convient à le département ok
très bien super classe quel est le
prénom de claude françois s'agit-il un
de claude ou deux de françois bonne
chance à tous deuxième indice pour vous
attention indice fort à me donner
réponse après parce qu'on n'a pas la
soirée indices en images vous le
reconnaissez célèbre aux séances et les
imams henri leconte
donc c'est un indice qui confirme le
précédent il nous faut une réponse
d'après vous quel est le prénom de notre
inconnus alors on joue ensemble donc on
lit ou retraités ruinés alors
concentrons on n'appelle pas un ami je
n'ai pas d'avis alors vous me dites
alors henry
inconnu vous appelez vous oui ou non
henry
[Musique]
non vous êtes montrés s'était pourtant
facile que votre prénom inconnu je
m'appelle daniel et oui daniel les
indices était pourtant évident la
chanson je m'appelle henry chanson de
daniel balavoine bien sûr et tout le
monde s'en souvient henri leconte a été
remplacé par daniel ducruet dans la
ferme célébrités on se souvient en 2005
c'est vrai peu de gens le savent mais ce
récit s'est passé pour pavoiser été sur
henri allard et puis voilà patatras quad
à l'écouté vous savez quoi c'est pas
tout je vous aime quand même vous ne
repartez pas les mains vides écouter ce
que vous avez gagné avec jean pierre
descombes
merci d une boîte de jeux en bois et
l'encyclo l'essentiel des connaissances
en un volume assez sympa et parce que je
vous aime beaucoup tous les deux je vous
offre également le temps de demain le
matin il fera beau saut presque toute la
france joli prénom france d'ailleurs
pour les températures il sera onze annen
6,15 à père et ses 12 à lurdes
l'après-midi un si grand soleil comme on
dit chez vous sophie à france 2 et pour
les températures je vous laisse l'ailier
vous êtes mieux caler en météo que moi
on en a une il fera combien toulouse
demain mardi 11 septembre nous fêterons
les adelphe
merci d'un an
[Applaudissements]